[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mon fils un jour tu
iras sur cette terre
là-bas dans les collineses
monte les
vignes les
oliviers les troupeaux et les
berger tu retrouveras la maison l'école
ou petit
garçon j'appris à lire et à
écrire à
dciné un pays sur mes
cahiers le long de la promenade les ré
si doux le ciel si beau on boit du thé à
la MTE et certains jou au
domino mon fils un jour tu
ira sur cette terre
là-bas dans cette
ville que ta
famille a dû quitter mais n'a jamais
oublié
l'herbe et les fleurs ont poussé
ou tant d'hommes sont tombés mais qui
s'exile quitte sa
ville toute sa vie connais le mal du
pays quand tu porteras mes lettres
demain à ceux que j'ai
connu tu verras de leur fenêtres c'est
ma jeunesse dans chaque
[Musique]
rue mon fils un jour tu
iras sur cette terre
là-bas dire aux frères et aux
amis combien j'y pense
à
[Musique]
Paris